hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Astro near once
again I'm joined by a Wolfie say hi hi
hi so I just wanted to mention as we
mentioned in the first one like
obviously we met through the make-a-wish
Foundation
but like I'm sure that people want more
details about what's going on if you're
willing to share them because it's oh
we've got a storm incoming just come on
jump in the pod jump in my not that wait
what are you gonna ride out the storm
and wait actually oh if I could pick you
up pick you won't let me pick you up
get out all right you're gonna be my
shield against the storm I'm gonna block
I got the flying debris with your chair
it will get through oh here comes oh god
oh god oh my sweet delicious body I'm
dead again oh god all of my stuff my
tethers my everything watch from the
sidelines no help what it won't ULB
you're such a jerk we had we had
titanium and super valuable stuff I got
it why did I point at it pick it up
where is it oh you're dead now great see
this is what happens when you help
people you die is that what happens is
that what I that's what happens how it
really happens okay you picked up the
titanium I'm picking it up you can keep
all that stupid resin alright all that
stuff that I got all that dumb stuff oh
yeah okay so anyway we were saying so
you're you're probably gonna have to go
through dialysis right right yeah and
for those that don't know
like dialysis is like a medical
procedure of filtering out when your
kidneys can't do the job right correct
yeah so it's something that's
interesting because Tyler actually went
through the same thing not the exact
same thing in terms of like why he
needed dialysis but the exact same
process and it it's really rough so like
I got a I got to commend you for like
taking with a brave face yeah I'm what
the weirdest thing about it is and I
talked to my doctor about it too and I
said I'm excited for my kidneys to fail
and the reason being is that I've been
dealing this with this for nearly a
decade now yeah so it's just finally
like I see a light at the end of the
tunnel gotcha gotcha
yeah well that's good and that's a big
reason I am I did YouTube because for
god knows how long I might you know not
be able to get a normal job I wanted to
do military but that probably won't work
out because I'll have had kidney surgery
it might but I really I've really come
to love doing YouTube yeah so that's
awesome yeah
glad to hear and and the only problems
that I'm looking at with dialysis is
like where you let me talk to Tyler it's
the whole like you don't feel like doing
anything and you feel sick all the time
and my federal astronauts not running
there we go and otherwise you know I'm
I'm just I'm fine yeah I gotcha I mean
that's it oh I found the compound mother
lode get over here we got a lot to farm
I am almost out of space I was gonna say
I came back because yeah the tethers ran
out oh that's okay because they're the
blue stuff around it is what you need to
be be able to blue stuff on the ground
like the blue squigglies that's oxygen
you can gather that the same way you can
gather like power and whatnot so that's
awfully helpful but I've got so much
compound here it is awesome it is
awesome ah Jesus shoulda came with a
full backpack yeah you shouldn't
okay I'm gonna go help where I can yeah
you help out where you can wear your
best needed so you go get what you want
to get good luck not asphyxiating don't
die out there if you die out there we
lose everything so don't do that
everything we lose everything
I'm gonna go back I'm gonna make more
tethers and then I'll be back and we'll
chain it out here so that we can get
more compound but don't die yes yes sir
you said don't die or die
don't don't die hey don't lie guys don't
get it out you got it don't it don't it
yes all right cool
so I'm gonna drop off some stuff I'm
gonna make more tethers I'm gonna
salvage some compound as we can but also
I need to make more space on these bad
boys here so I need to extend the do
burrs come on out and there we go oxygen
I'm not getting oxygen from this yeah
the blue stuff is oxygen why are you not
getting oxygen
[Music]
well don't Donna Donna die just oh
goodness what are you doing are you
dying they're suffocating feels like no
come on man did you die I think not to
do and you do it I'm a rule breaker wait
which way did we go just follow the X of
my death oh no you have no idea actually
there we go dude there we go Wow such a
big boy he knows exactly where he's
going all right come with me I got more
tethers what I was gonna take compound
so that we could no leave the compound
there I've got tethers you let me do the
Tigers all right I'm the boss here
answers all I gotta say about that make
sense good I think I made my point
I'm your uncle are you my that's it
that's all that I got I've got
bag full of I'm just your uncle
here's your body as your grandpa always
told me yep
think I made my point all right oh shoot
I'm like you you go you go get fast food
yeah I'd like uh can I get a number you
just don't leave it yeah
so I'm s I mean you pull up and they're
like you didn't order anything you use
me I ordered my favorite my favorite
thing is just always the the overly
dramatic I don't think you understand I
work sure excuse me I love a good excuse
me
all right so I'm gonna just I place the
rest of the tethers going down into that
cave but we need to focus on the
compound here so there's tons of it so
just grab a pan filled up with it now
okay cool I'm gonna rake it right back
oh we got so much compound Oh hurry up
Cheez Whiz why's your name Wolfie halt
my name I can't be I already told you
this I'm outside the box but not really
cuz I was just like no excuse me I
already told you this um yeah there you
go believe it a nice quiet jog excuse me
I got a bag full of apples and yeah
that's what I thought that's what I
thought
all right we got to make more what is
this and I'm gonna make let's see blink
I'm just gonna extend out these because
for right now I don't want to build
platforms I want to build a do bird a
verse what is the beacon wasn't the H&H
yes what the H&M is a beacon
what is a beacon anyway no I'm gonna
make one I wonder if it just tells you I
died here yeah that's probably just an
identifying locator not really anything
important you brush it and waste all
your energy building one of those that
beasts to do we won't lose our base now
oh great it wasn't like there was a
giant home marker for that anyway so
yeah I'm just gonna build some solar
panels because that's something actually
useful to do for this base that's you
that's what you sound like look at it
it's called hydro-zone excuse me excuse
me check your priveledge so I need more
storage space I don't have enough of it
so I'm just gonna drop it on the ground
and what it'll look print you do a
printer then like like we're we need to
type in that's it
yeah good job there with your commentary
very smart very doctor he's getting in
the way I asked them to take him out you
guys here to take him out the teeth
authority all right come with me we're
going into the first game system because
we got to go find some copper and we got
to go find some aluminum we need these
heavy metals to be able to build you
need to do is your inventory empty it
better be and I have two things I'll
just drop them because it's organic yeah
you don't need a removing compound all
right I'll just keep that in case we
need more tethers yeah okay you do that
cuz I don't have anymore to others oh
god I'm falling there we go hey there's
a there's something down here there's
like some what kind of like satellite
there's a lot of things down here hmm
wow thanks man also fun is this it's so
goopy I don't know but there's oh it's
gooping why is there what is this it's a
satellite there's a frickin satellite
down there what but why is a satellite
under down Wow
it hurt me it killed me yeah don't go
wait what it killed me I got you dude I
jumped I jumped on that goopy thing I
know I know I should jump on goofy
things and in yoga I found some I found
a dead body down here and it has
dynamite on it I've never seen dynamite
in my life this is the case happens that
time comes we have to decide
you got Dino okay I think I see some a
valuable resource down here it's gonna
try to grab it try to grab it up coming
this time
Oh ow Ethel do that it'll free your back
Oh malachite that's copper ore that's
right that's copper ore that's good okay
this is good she's good
oh I did I died it was the green gasps
yeah the gas there's like the plants
that shoot green fart gas at you and if
you breathe it in and you die which
doesn't make any sense we got we've got
we've got like frickin helmets
yeah helmets yes is the word I was
looking for we've got elements yeah we
know breathe your air we breathe us air
better
air better good it makes good air do
don't take my stuff the others down you
press T T put them back in your
inventory press T got it got it
oh jeez that was good I was I was
unbreathing yeah you got a pill I don't
I unn
unbreathing it was no good like in the
water oh god oh god it's following me
yeah don't let it get you don't let it
get you whatever you do don't let it get
you are you letting it get yeah you
shouldn't let it get you following me so
far yeah I know it vide likes to do that
it wants to do that okay I got a
Oh farts okay I gotta go back you're on
your own
screw you I hate you no way whoa I found
you dead body it was kono it's not my
boy no someone that's someone else I
don't know what are you talking about
never died for you I never died I died
two weeks ago those nice things died to
me yeah exactly
we think I'm crazy I'm crazy oh I got a
research cool good for you bring it back
I've got copper I'm gonna put in the
smelter and this copper is gonna be able
to turn into something fart on me oh god
it's farting on me okay all right run
faster so I'm gonna smelt up this stuff
like the boss I am huh laughter when you
smelt point charge sweet nice I'm
smelling up a crazy storm and then I'm
gonna build the printer clouds smelting
clouds yeah we're gonna really we're
ruining this this place the beauty of
this place is being like horribly
thrashed because we keep filling it with
our smaller it doesn't matter we need
things the environment can take the hit
whatever
anyway I'm building a printer now just
so you know I built a printer I forget
my god I fell don't why did you let me
make that hole you fell in why'd you
fall in the hole oh my god oh the stole
the solar panel is freaking out oh my
god you're so far away can you just run
and pick this up for me so I don't have
to mmm no I cannot I will not be respect
that respect Thanks thanks for
respecting it I like to take initiative
and all that I do I think I think it
deserves all the respect in the world oh
yeah I appreciate you understanding that
all right I gotta build one of these is
the croc open an egg right go up the
research station you dummy
that one I did it yeah the research
station
taking this one good Oh at least you did
it right this time excuse excuse me
rocks excuse me get out of my way was it
not a robot why that was a useful
research man I'm so glad oh you don't
know what an arrow rod mod is know what
I Niro mod is I thought you were an
expert at this game man seems like
there's some things that you don't
understand that I want to know if you
know so you explain it oh oh you'd like
that if I explained it well I'm not
gonna give you the satisfaction of me
and explaining it because that's too
good for you yeah got you there I got
you there why why you used tricking me
with this he knows oh no it's impossible
all right I'm gonna go back in the cave
so you can either join me or die that's
what you can do I'm a moment um your
ooming them I'm moving on
I gotta find a moving them a moving them
Oh a moving them you need to go down in
the caves and you need to scavenge more
[ __ ] and you need to get it make
sounds cool yeah also get more
researchable z' because those are
important heck yeah I think I found one
there was another one over here
somewhere
Oh poison just run from it I can't run
what I have the researchable but I'm
gonna try I adds tricky oh my dynamite
how can I forget my dynamite
yeah just blow it up maybe yes maybe I
can't blow it up I'd like to think I
could blow it up
yeah okay I'm gonna try to get over
there I've got gaseous following me I'm
sucking on something yes suck harder
resin I don't need a [ __ ] prison Oh
what you live with me rock your damned
language what's your [ __ ] language
this isn't my wolfy this isn't the wolfy
I know the wolfy I know wouldn't say
[ __ ]
Oh YouTube changed you man YouTube
changed you
markiplier changed you man how could you
let that happen
you betrayed us I knew you when you were
just Luke what happened dude oh now
you're wolfy and Oh gross
you didn't even spell it right god oh
yeah is it wolf hey what is wrong with
you yeah you sure did didn't you miss
the research hang on this way we stay
far away from big holes but I want to
dive on in
well you're only good at sucking you're
not good at filling big holes so don't
do that had to be one or the other why
did I pick sucking hydrazine
I think excuse you what the hell did you
just say what are you talking about I
have hydrazine for the medium generator
isn't that how generators work sure I
guess hey I'm gonna come over to you and
I'm gonna test out my dynamite okay okay
doc let me see if there's a specific
control to test out the dynamite
probably dee dee is turn right you
stupid goof is it why might Wow
yeah yeah you feel dumb just cut that
part out none of that don'ts going in no
yeah no see that's the thing about
YouTube you can't cut out anything
mistakes live with you for life you have
to let people judge you on them yes
please everyone judges me so they have
to judge you too
all right I'm gonna build I'm gonna
build a few more tether e weathers and
then I'm gonna go what is an arrow mod
wait I can build an arrow mod I'm gonna
I'm gonna build a bigger sure it's what
you put in your eye on prey
what oh god oh god storm I'm running an
arrow mod its ability of words neuroma
you know what you didn't get
like it's barely go it's an OGG you
thought I meant like go to the church
and pray to the Father no I didn't think
you meant that at all I didn't even hear
the word pray what you hear I don't know
you being dumb because you're out in the
middle of nowhere when a storm's rolling
in the head with a rock you know what
I'm gonna build a really big hole and go
in doof it doesn't matter that I get out
you couldn't just come over here and get
it in the pod I didn't think I'd make it
this might not have been smart eh yeah
no the rocks aren't even there yet is it
still that story storm missed you
entirely it didn't even hit us it wasn't
even here excuse you who gave me this
idea who gave you the right who told you
who my dad was where did you find my
uncle
I think I made my point
think about it all right I've got an
I've got an I've got an arrow kill me
what the Frick does an arrow mod do I
don't know
stick it on something I did it didn't
seem to go nowhere
it sits on this research station but
that doesn't seem to do it well I'm
looking at your guy my guy I'm really
big oh wait yeah oh that's how you do
the dynamite you set it down and then
you just blast it okay all right that
mountain yeah I'm gonna plug you read my
mind mr. Wolfman you read my mind
you and I we're gonna blow the [ __ ] out
of this mountain I'm gonna teach it
you've been learning how to suck all
these years but now now it's time for me
to teach you the sacred art hard blow
get ready buddy here we are
ah yes this isn't real nice here I can
already feel like a reverb of blow
coming on
oh yeah it's it's the blow coming back
three if through the through the various
mountains here we go
you've delighted
[Laughter]
whoa not very impressive by hard you
know how's it good enough I'm gonna dig
into his mountain I'm gonna dig up this
man cool you do that stupid no it's too
hard I give up already oh man I hope you
don't actually commit to anything else
in your life be so fast I love digging
digging it dub ass seems like this is a
bad idea to keep digging down here but
you know what oh no just just dig
straight down
you got to land on something what have
you fall through down to a precipice um
let me show you bye oh my god goodbye
I'm gonna try to put tether down there
for you Oh gasps yes yes I try I'm
trying to build tethers but they didn't
they didn't land I think that's a good
place to end this episode so thank you
everybody so much for watching
wolf he's gonna deal with this gas
problem down there so thank you
everybody so much for watching any last
words Wolfie help me
nope can't do so thanks again and as
always we will see you in the next video
[Music]